Я навчався на історичному факультеті,
і на першому курсі магістратури побачив,
що в Стендфордському університеті
запустили масові відкриті онлайн-курси,
які стали надзвичайно популярними.
Я подумав: «Окей, це революція в освіті,
ми маємо зробити щось подібне в Україні».
Тому вирушив до проректора університету,
отримав дозвіл на зйомки і ми почали знімати.
«Prometheus» — це платформа онлайн-курсів,
яка має просту в формулюванні,
але складну в досягненні мету —
надати доступ до найкращої освіти всім охочим.
Конкретна форма реалізації цієї ідеї —
побудова екосистеми партнерів,
які створюють онлайн-курси з нашою допомогою.
Комусь ми допомагаємо лише методично,
для когось знімаємо, монтуємо курси,
але викладачів, ресурси під це
збирають зазвичай партнери.
Ми ж надаємо платформу, надаємо
розуміння найкращих практик,
надаємо аудиторію в півтора мільйона слухачів.
І останній рік поступово намагаємося переходити
й до соціального підприємництва.
Ми намагаємося запускати
платні курси з партнером,
прибутки з яким реінвестуємо
в безкоштовні курси,
на які ніхто не хоче давати гроші.
Співвідношення безкоштовних
і платних курсів на платформі
це 95 проти 5%.
Тобто переважна більшість повністю безкоштовна.
Зараз ми в школі журналістики
Києво-Могилянської Академії.
Тут ми можемо побачити саму студію,
за подвійними дверима безпосередньо зона зйомок,
де просто зараз знімається один з наших курсів.
Перший, такий найлегший, варіант —
покликати знайомих, друзів, одногрупників.
Просто пишіть їм у телеграмі:
«Привіт, класний кемп, хочеш зі мною, давай разом».
Це направду гарний варіант, бо це швидко,
ви вже одне одного знаєте і вам точно буде весело.
Але враховуйте, що часом бу... [сміється]
Можемо звідси почати. Всяке буває.
Нічого. Фрейд нам переказує вітання.
На старті ми взагалі не розуміли, що робити,
не розуміли, як шукати викладачів.
Тоді нас ніхто не знав.
Ми прийшли, попросили дозволу в проректора,
він дозволив користуватися
студією університету Шевченка,
там ще були старі відеокамери,
де касети потрібно було купляти.
Ми пішли на радіоринок купили ці касети.
Зняли, змонтували, випустили.
І несподівано це стало дуже популярним.
Багато телеканалів, ЗМІ зробило
якісь матеріали, сюжети про це.
Ми зрозуміли, що за це потрібно взятися серйозно.
І тоді заснували «Prometheus»
як повноцінну незалежну організацію,
яка займалась онлайн-освітою в Україні.
Це було як зробити щось, що здавалося неможливим.
Я прийшов до одного крутого фахівця в ІТ-сфері,
він сказав мені, що ця ідея ніби хороша,
але потрібен мільйон доларів на її втілення.
Каже: «Скільки в тебе є зараз?».
Кажу: «Слухай, в мене є десь
дві тисячі доларів, які я десь там зберіг,
якісь підробітки, стипендії і так далі».
Тоді це було по факту просто волонтерство.
Далі ми провели невеличку
краудфандингову кампанію.
Тоді нас помітив через публікації
в ЗМІ фонд «Відродження».
І відтоді почалася наша співпраця з донорами,
тобто ми почали або донорам, або
замовникам, або великим компаніям
робити на замовлення курси,
від «Prozorro» робили для них
навчальні курси з децентралізації.
Ми підтримували реформи протидії корупції,
робили курси, які мали просувати ІТ в Україні,
навчати програмування, підприємництва.
Ми робили курси для дітей
з тимчасово окупованих територій,
щоб вони могли вивчати,
наприклад, українську мову онлайн.
Бо ми всі знаємо,
що окупанти не дозволяють
викладати українську мову в школах.
Я з Донецька. Росія окупувала Донецьк,
коли ми тільки починали, це був 2014 рік.
Це Майдан, це початок війни.
І у нас було бажання, звичайно,
здійснити якийсь свій вклад.
На старті був великий скепсис про те,
що така платформа українською взагалі потрібна.
Хто зацікавлений навчитися онлайн,
він навчатиметься на західних
платформах на «Coursera» і так далі.
Але по факту виявилося по-іншому:
українські онлайн-курси —
це не тільки про українську мову,
це не тільки про доступність,
а ще й про специфіку,
бо багато специфіки:
українська історія, українське право,
українські державні реформи,
про них курси ніхто не зробить, крім українців.
І навіть у тих темах, які здаються універсальними,
як-от підприємництво,
теж багато української специфіки.
Привіт.
Радий, що нарешті зйомки почалися,
що вже йде повним ходом.
Так, вже ж прямо біжить, крутиться.
Це Ukraїner до нас прийшов зніматись.
Коли нам потрібно було шість років тому
з'ясувати, де ж знімати це,
коли в нас не було грошей,
не було грантів, не було нічого.
Мій друг Богдан, студент
Києво-Могилянської академії на той момент,
сказав: «Іди до Юри Паніна, технічного директора
Києво-Могилянської школи журналістики, попроси студію».
Я кажу: «Ну, Бодя, як?
Я просто прийду скажу:
"Мене звати Іван Приймаченко, дай мені студію"».
Він каже: «Ну, спробуй».
Так і сталося — я прийшов до Юри,
сказав: «Мене звати Іван, дай мені студію».
Він питає: «Надовго?». — «Надовго».
І відтоді ми тут дуже багато знімаємо.
Минулого року, коли почався карантин,
локдауни, велика кількість людей зайшла на платформу.
Але більш важлива метрика — це відсоток людей,
які успішно закінчують курси,
кількість виданих сертифікатів
про успішне завершення навчання.
І ми за минулий рік видали більше
сертифікатів про успішне навчання,
ніж за всі попередні роки разом узяті.
Тобто я думаю, це найоб'єктивніший показник того,
наскільки розвивається «Prometheus».
У Львівській області є кейс,
коли використовують центр
для дітей з неблагополучних родин,
та наші курси для того, щоб навчати їх ІТ-навичок.
У нас був кейс, коли хлопець у 15 років
почав навчатися програмувати онлайн,
знайшов у нас, здається,
на форумі курсу однодумців.
Вони почали робити ІТ-стартап.
І він фактично в 16 років
почав працювати програмістом,
навчившись на онлайн-курсі.
З минулого року вчителі можуть нарешті навчатися
в недержавних закладах освіти
або просто на таких платформах, як «Prometheus»,
тепер це визнається як підвищення
кваліфікації вчителя офіційно.
Людина може відкрити топові курси
від найкращих викладачів України
чи навіть світу і на «Prometheus»
безкоштовно їх пройти
і безкоштовно отримати сертифікат
й отримати потім атестацію державного зразка.
Це фантастика. В більшості
країн світу подібного ще немає,
і тут це те, чим Україна може пишатися.
Це ну дуже круто.
Ми контактували і контактуємо
зі Стенфордом, Гарвардом,
МІТ, Колумбійським університетом,
отримуємо дозвіл на переклад,
перекладаємо найкращі їхні курси українською,
професійно дублюємо і даємо безкоштовний доступ,
тобто на «Coursera» умовно
ти маєш 60 доларів заплатити,
щоб отримати сертифікат,
на «Prometheus» ти можеш пройти
цей курс безкоштовно українською,
безкоштовно отримати сертифікат.
Я думаю, що це дуже важливо для інтеграції українців
в західне освітнє середовище,
в західний освітній світ.
Мені здається, в нас завжди
був такий спосіб мислення:
мінімальним ресурсами давати
найбільший позитивний вплив.
І, звичайно, коли ти бачиш, що в це
вкладається кілька тисяч доларів,
а на виході 100 тисяч людей отримують
доступ до навчання світового рівня,
ти розумієш, навіщо працюєш.
Я думаю, що соціально орієнтовані бізнеси
в найближчі десятиліття стануть нормою.
Всі бізнеси рано чи пізно мають
стати соціально відповідальними
і виконувати певну місію.
Я щиро переконаний, що людська
цивілізація може змінитися на краще,
значно на краще.
Якщо ми дамо доступ до кращої освіти всім охочим.
Це був би, напевно, такий
найбільш універсальний вклад
в прискорення розвитку людства,
який в принципі можна зробити.
І в Україні є вже галузі,
є вже певні моменти,
які справді найкращі в світі.
Я хотів би, щоб такого ставало більше.
Я хотів би, щоб про Україну говорили
як про передову країну в світі.
І це, напевно, те, над чим
я буду радий працювати.